and so you guys go and you launch and
you kind of took the world by storm
right in terms of you really hit
marketing and the affiliate programs and
all of that in a kind of a big way maybe
talk through a little bit once you guys
had built the product what were those
things that you did to kind of get the
word out and really start driving
adoption a very good question actually
is one of the questions I haven't talked
about so much it's I think what we've
very original stage that early stage
that we did sort of something that
changed the industry is how affiliation
system works so when we built the launch
the Bitcoin perpetual contract in
December 2018 after about three months
there wasn't so much volume and interest
coming in we realized we need to focus
on really getting people to know our
product so this is a game based on my
previous effects knowledge which is very
developed in the affiliation system and
program we looked at the competition of
course board there was PMAC so kex and
even finance the affiliation is more of
a referral program it's a very simple
page with your link and that's it so and
then we sort of talked through all of
the chaos at the time you tubers Twitter
guys and you know across all of the
globe and their feedback was that their
main source of income was mainly from a
shout out well I give you a shout out I
charge you you know 200 bucks and this
type of deal I realized what they could
be making so much money and utilizing
their dear-dear conversion and their
traffic by simply working on a
affiliation deal but they couldn't do so
because the data was not there the data
was not transparent it could not and
analyze their action so what we did is
we basically built a affiliate CRM for
them to be able to at least see the and
create different campaigns so they for
you palm you can create a YouTube
campaign a Twitter campaign with
different campaign you can use different
links with different links we give you
all the toppings or the clicks how many
clicks how many conversions how much how
much traffic was coming in
so in a way you cannot you can you can
start to see the testing their behavior
so they could be saying by a bit check
out by a bit it's no overload and then
they leave it for a week and the next
one they could say check out by a bit
there is no kyc for example so which
ever link has more traffic they will be
pushing that link more and then sort of
really develop their whole energy into
into promoting a exchange so after we
launched that along with that there was
a also a spike in price movement in
April of 2019 that really give us a huge
a lot of a client position and you can
start to see that what we changed is
that from being charging shoutouts
affiliates are now fully being a baby
promoter and actually can learn the
income so so this is a way we originally
started how people get to know them but
obviously once you get people to know
them retention is the key is to actually
have a solid product so that client try
and they like you they stay so we
actually have one of the highest
retention in the industry we have a
thing almost 60% so every ten people who
register by a bit would end up making
deposit is sixty percent of them so this
is because our product is user friendly
it's built for retail and they can find
us 24/7 for the customer support all of
that whole package so in the end it is
the whole package but in the beginning
this is what we did to get the initial
ball rolling and I think one of the
other things that I've heard people talk
about with my bit is not only was it
really built for an analytic standpoint
around the affiliate program but also
the way that you compensated people in
that affiliate program was kind of
unique and so I've heard a lot of people
come to me and say hey look like I make
more money with by bit than any other
exchange that I work with maybe talk a
little bit of just about that that
compensation structure and how you guys
thought about that and built it the
composition is rather simple but people
I get I guess once you give them food
transparency we don't give them the
client information of course but they
can actually see that if a you IP is
registered because the UID is an
internal by bit number so there is
nothing conflict about that they can see
a UID registered how much it's been
trade either is taker volume or or maker
volume and how much commission they be
made from that client and if they create
different campaign they can actually
target let's say if I'm in the signal
group I can see the ROI on my signal
group or versus the my discord group
let's say so with the data transparency
it gives a lot of finished ideas that
they can make more and all that but I
believe true they probably could make
more because the product the retention
or all of that in terms of payment we
just give them a card on the honor fees
we collected so we charge our clients a
taker fee of 7.5 bits which is a same as
industry standard and we also give a
rebate on whoever providing us an
equality by giving a 2.5 bits
rebate on the maker volume and the
affiliates would share that taker volume
share that taker volume fees another
reason it is because the platform is
overall it builds for retail a lot of
retail clients tends to use a taker
strategy so that is why if they compare
with let's say B Max or FTX maybe I've
takes as a lot of Kwan's or API traders
which can be a lot of maker volume so I
guess that whole thing we built for a
retail and they have retail audience
that's what makes by bit is very good
for conversion so I don't think is the
actual payment structure but is the
product is built for their clients so
they have a better conversion in the end
they get better paid for for the
Commission yeah